hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast rapid whole genome
sequencing in the NICU and PICU at Rady
Children's Hospital presented by shamil
Chowdhury the clinical laboratory
director at Rady Children's Institute
for genomic medicine i'm susie valdez of
lab routes and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we're delighted to
bring this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
kyochon molecular diagnostics for more
information about our sponsor please
visit their website at WWE
I dare mind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on a green Q&A button located at the
lower left of your presentation window
and type your questions into the box
that appear on the screen well answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be view viewing the
presentation in a stride window to
enlarge that window just click on the
screen icon located at the lower right
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
problems this presentation is
educational and that offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left hand corner
and follow the process to obtain your
credit please ringing out in welcoming
dr. Chimel chattery I will now turn the
presentation over to him welcome sir
thank you very
for that nice introduction and I'm
honored to be here to speak in this
platform about some of the work that
we've been performing at Rady Children's
Hospital as I said my name is Shmuel
Chaudhary i'm a laboratory director at
the Rady Children's Institute for
genomic medicine so a little bit about
the genomics Institute and what our
mission is I have a slide here to try
and capture what we're trying to do so
our mission statement States we're we're
trying to prevent diagnose treat and
cure childhood diseases through genomic
and systems medicine research you know
that's kind of a mouthful in terms of a
mission statement when you talk about
what we're trying to do to the
population so we try to simplify it a
little bit so what is our vision to say
is 6,000 children's quality adjusted
life years through rapid genome
sequencing by 2020 so we speak often in
our world about qualities is quality
adjusted life years adding quality leap
years these children's lives by using
genome sequencing and that are very you
know basic message in our motto is going
big for the little ones and what we mean
by that is performing genome sequencing
rapidly for the tiniest of humans out
there as we've seen in our short time up
at the Institute providing a huge impact
for these patients and so how we got
here to this point being able to think
about and providing genome sequencing
within a couple days well it wasn't that
long ago that we performed the human
genome project which took over 13 years
and passed over three billion dollars
then with some of the new
next-generation sequencing or massive
parallel sequencing technologies now
sequencing a genome was possible within
a day and a half and for the price of
thousands of dollars and I think for all
of us in the laboratory world we
envision in picture a time where we'll
be able to sequence genomes in a day for
hundreds of dollars really making that
price feasible to reimburse this testing
for children all over the country and so
sequencing technology companies such as
alumina we're really driving this board
and being able to make sequencing
cheaper and
or robust so who are we and what are the
patients that we serve this is a picture
of our acute care for building at Rady
Children's Hospital that houses our NICU
located in San Diego California and so
here you see a quote from Ernest ray T
who provided a generous gift of 120
million dollars for us to be able to
people men history of providing genomic
medicine in the NICU at Rady and
throughout the country
and so I think this quote really serves
it well serves this mission well
children are an underserved community as
far as research goes their smaller
market segments they're overlooked and
we we really see this as well and that
there are many children that need
genomic testing need rapid genomic
testing and they're not able to get this
and so our mission at the genomic
institute is to make this a reality and
show other institutions other children's
hospitals that this is possible so as we
look at our landscape at rating our
patient population you know there are
multiple components multiple types of
genetic diseases out there with
different impacts and differing costs so
as you can see in this scale for 10
percent of the kids
within our hospital system they actually
incur 70% of the total cost and these
are generally kids with the rare and
undiagnosed diseases these are the kids
that we've seen you can provide a
highest bang for your buck in terms of
quality adjusted life years if you go
down to the other triangles you see that
there are more children within some of
these other buckets healthy children
seventy-six percent these are the kids
that are coming into the hospital and
then getting better and and then getting
discharged and high risk children
comprising a 14% but again you see that
significant cost burden within these ten
percent of children that potentially
could have severe genetic disease and so
we wanted to focus on these children
with rare and undiagnosed disease seeing
that has the biggest impact in our in
our costs for our public health systems
and the highest potential for providing
more quality adjusted life years for
these children
and so a stat that I always get startled
by whenever I see the slide even though
I presented multiple times 14% of us do
burns are admitted to it NICU and so
some of those children will be there for
a few days and they'll be released but
there are also many other children in
Nick use that have severe genetic
disease and are not able to get the
testing that they're need that is needed
and so here's a picture of our CEO and
president dr. Stephen Kingsmore we came
from Children's Mercy in Kansas City and
really wanted to implement some of the
groundbreaking work that he performed in
performing rapid sequencing an intensive
care unit population so the solution to
the problem so the leading cause of
death in the NICU in PICU is genetic
disease conventional testing is too slow
to guide NICU in PICU care so sending
out a panel test for a series of genes
for your condition of interest average
turnaround time in the market is right
around 4 to 6 weeks within the scope of
a few critically ill children in the
NICU this is too slow at the same time
the majority of these genetic conditions
are simple genetic conditions so single
gene disorders that we can interpret
right now in 2017 with the right tools
and great infrastructure so for this
burden that we have and depending on
where you look at the numbers it can be
between 5,000 and 8,000 genetic diseases
we did Nick doing PICU we really feel a
rapid genome sequencing Israel has a
potential to be a great first-line test
to help our position help our nurses and
the frontline taking care of these
patients by giving them the ability to
use rapid whole genome sequencing and so
here's kind of a snapshot of some of the
work that dr. Kingsmore had performed
previously in his work in providing the
Guinness Book of World Records from 26
hours from sample in the door to call
out a provisional report for a patient
and this was actually described as one
of the
the top breakthroughs in 2012 and by
Time magazine and so again applying this
rapid whole genome sequencing for
intensive care unit population is a
novel concept but we've seen in multiple
institutions that dr. Kingsmore has LED
radiant and the city that this approach
really works and so here's a snapshot of
our experience at Rady Children's
Hospital over a six-month period when we
started our clinical research protocol
so we had referred 116 families 58
enrolled and we were able to enroll 95
percent of the families approach so that
really speaks to the trust that we have
within our nurses in our NICU Doc's in
enrolling into this study and in turn
allowing those families to trust in the
information that we're providing as part
of the research protocol we also enroll
to external patients as well in
critically ill children and so 40 of
families are tested at the end of this
data point and we're able to provide a
diagnosis for 48 percent of those
children so 23 diagnoses our fastest
diagnosis to date was 43 hours and 16
infants receive changes in care and so
that could be a variety of things that
I'll talk about in the next slide but
basically what the snapshot is show has
shown us is that rapid whole genome
sequencing not only can help to provide
a rapid diagnosis in these kids but can
have downstream impacts in changing the
care in these individuals so here are
some of our early results from the
sequencing studies so for the percent of
infants tested comparing what they'd
seen in Kansas City compared to what
we've seen in San Diego so you see a
very similar diagnosis rate at the time
that this data was captured for those
children that were diagnosed a
significant amount of them had changes
in care 78% for San Diego 52% for Kansas
City the changes in those care could be
anything from palliative care guidance
the medication change life-saving
treatments and also avoiding posted
potential surgeries as well so again
you can see the clinical utility and the
downstream impact of this testing really
providing a strong case for rapid whole
genome sequencing so what is needed to
really make this happen
obviously upstream you need to be able
to perform sequencing very rapidly for
whole genome sequencing you also need an
informatics pipeline
let's able to process the sequencing
data and get it into a VCF format that
out that my team that we can look at in
terms of filtering out variants and
taking the VCF and taking it all the way
to the clinical report so within our
workflow we have the Illumina sequencers
that can perform the sequencing within a
day and a half we have our informatics
pipeline of taking the sequencing data
to VCF using the editor dragon pipeline
which allows the alignment and variant
calling within an hour for genome and
through the use of the tool of the
kaijin insight platform we're able to
take a VCF into report and we've been
able to do it in a rapid amount of time
very important for us is to be able to
annotate that VCF and get the proper
annotations that we need to be able to
interpret the genome do rapid filtering
and eventually get a concise clinical
report to our physicians so they can
comprehend that information and so IG
provides a great platform for us in
being able to filter by various
mechanisms being able to take our
phenotypic information what is the
patient presenting with categorize that
using ACMG criteria for variant
classification and then pull in the
relevant variants into a clinical report
and so now I want to go through three
case examples that we've seen within our
Hospital that I summarized before and
kind of walk you through that process
the presentations that these kiddos had
and going through how long it took us to
make a diagnosis of what were the
downstream impacts so our first case is
kind of a non-traditional case in terms
of this was not a child in the intensive
care unit but is a child that
desperately needed the testing so we had
a previously how
the 16 year old female with cardiac
arrest so she actually had to be
defibrillated two times uh you know
while she was actually out playing with
their friends when she went into cardiac
arrest and after those episodes she
actually remained chronically fatigued
for a year when she was found to be
anemic with men our Asia and so this is
just showing that uh you know there was
some cardiac problem that was occurring
there was a suspicion of ctvt
but we didn't have a definitive
diagnosis for this child and so we had
the opportunity to sequence this child
and her parents and perform rapid whole
genome sequencing and so based off of
the great notes that we had from our
physicians and our cardiologists at
rating we knew that cpdt
was one of the phenotypes that this
child was presenting with and so within
this platform you're able to add ctvt as
one of the terms it will take the
variant information and and then
prioritize the variants according to
that side of things and so as you can
see here in the screenshot you're you're
able to see the direct link between a
particular gene all ir-2 and this
particular variant CP for this
particular phenotype CBD and so what we
were able to find in this patient is
that we had a variance that pop up to
the top of our list very quickly and all
ir2 gene that had been strongly
associated with CP VG as well and so the
algorithms placed it very close to the
top of the list we were then able to
take those variants and perform the
classifications according to the ACMG
criteria and so off of the first
iteration from the software a classified
this variant of uncertain significance
because it didn't have the family
information prior and so this period was
actually found in oval so it's not found
in the parents and based off of that
this variant then was pushed up to
likely pathogenic and that it was a rare
variant and
served region beam de novo and also
being in a gene that had been implicated
in CP VG previously and so with that
we're able to make a genetic diagnosis
of CP VT R if we also found two cases in
the literature with the same variant
with people with CP VT and so here I put
a couple quotes from our cardiologists
that was taking care of this child in
terms of what a genetic diagnosis meant
for their future care of this individual
and so we state the knowledge of her
definitive mutation allowed me to feel
comfortable adding pluck and I'm so beta
blocker for the best mutation specific
therapy and arrhythmia suppression
having her own flecainide at the time
made me very comfortable to proceed with
far less concern of an inch or
procedural life-threatening DT and so we
actually done an update and this child
is doing well at last check this is just
last week and we were able to provide
the diagnosis very rapidly and we were
able to call it out to the cardiologist
on call at the hospital we actually made
a diagnosis on this I believe is a
Friday after Thanksgiving and so this
was a great instance of providing a
rapid diagnosis handing downstream
effects on therapeutic targets and
implications and another interesting
part of this story that speaks to the
power of genetics and how genetic
testing is not just for a patient but
for their entire family is that this
child also had half siblings that the
parents were concerned about this
particular genetic diagnosis presenting
in those children and so we were able to
actually do targeted testing for those
children to let them know that they
didn't have the variant and so that
their risk wasn't increased over what
the background risk would be for a child
with an R Y are two related cpdt
okay so now for case two so a very
different presentation here and that we
had a three day old female photonic and
myoclonic seizures and what we saw in
this child so they were transferred to
our NICU at Rady shortly after birth the
first line treatments for stopping the
seizures anti-epileptics were all
ineffective so we enrolled this child
into our protocol to run rapid low
genome sequencing and so after the
sequencing was quorum performed
informatics
was been conducted we now moved into the
variant interpretation and filtering so
again I want to just kind of show the
slide of what we're seeing on my am from
the interpretation and reporting side of
things as we analyze the case and one of
the points that I really want to drive
home with the analysis of genomic data
is that you need to be able to have high
quality sequencing data upfront we also
need high quality phenotypic information
to really help make rapid diagnosis and
so we have a team of people that are
really digging into the medical records
to provide strong phenotypic information
for us to do our analysis and so as you
can see in this slide here we put in
features that was the main indication
for this child and so these are the
variants now as you merge that
phenotypic driven prioritization with
the genomic data that's coming through
and so you know we just had a handful of
candidates that came through including a
candidate in the kc n q2 gene as you can
see it's involved in a seizure disorder
and so that seemed like a very strong
candidate for us to pursue further and
so we honed in on the kc n q2 variant
this was a missense variant again we had
parents in the scenario so it was a de
novo missense grand again i found in
either parents and a conserved residue
and even though this period was
unreported there were multiple variants
right around this amino acid change that
had been reported pathogenic before the
phenotypic overlap was very strong in
terms of the NICU and the neurologist
had a suspicion of aha
syndrome this child based off of some of
the imaging studies that have been done
and this gene is a very strong candidate
has a very strong overlap with or the
artisan girl and so for this particular
case we actually made a diagnosis in 96
hours so we're able from our blood
sample in the door to perform sequencing
informatics interpretation and calling
the results of the physician in 96 hours
and so the very gratifying thing of this
particular case the gratifying case is
that the molecular diagnosis actually
indicated a very specific treatment
regimen so with children with kcn q2o
Tahara centromere and some allopathy
there's a very specific treatment
regimen that is recommended it's been
well published in the literature and so
first-line treatment actually will not
work for children that have the DCN q2
pathogenic variants so after receiving
this information the seizures were
controlled and the charge and child was
able to be discharged shortly after so
this was really a success story for us
and just to quote from one of our
neurologists that this potentially could
be the fastest molecular seizure
diagnosis that's ever been made
worldwide we can't prove that but it was
very gratifying story for our team to be
able to provide this diagnosis for for
these children and for this particular
child and so an interesting side note
that I want to make for this particular
case is we'd love to have comparisons of
why would our testing be better I do
want to bring up the point that yes if
you sent out a panel testing for KCM QQ
and if you were suspected of seizure
disorders they were - picked up this
diagnosis that's exactly what happened
in a child that they had a tradie last
year so having a case enq to diagnosis
is not a very common thing but they had
a child with the same scenario last year
before we were up and sequencing at our
Institute
so they sent out for standard genetic
testing for this child and they came
back with the key cmq to diagnosis but
that diagnosis came six weeks later and
so the child was seizing in the NICU for
six weeks and could not discharge be
discharged for a large amount of time
and so in addition to the cost that goes
into a child sting in the NICU that long
the emotional stress on the family
there's potential implication showing
the literature that obviously for a
young child that is seizing that much
there is a potential for downstream
effects neurologically and in terms of
the life lifetime of this child and what
it means neurodevelopmental II so again
this is an interesting study for us to
go back talk with in the neurology team
in terms of what to dis rapid diagnosis
mean compared to other diagnoses you
have made from standard clinical genetic
testing in the past and so this was a
good case comparison for us and so the
last case that I'm going to go through
here it's a case of a child with
congenital hyperinsulinism and the
child's condition was deteriorating and
so they weren't exactly sure what the
cause could be so they actually had to
transport the child to Children's
Hospital of Philadelphia do a very
detailed imaging scan a very expensive
imaging scan try and determine if
something was wrong with the pancreas
and what exactly that could be at the
same time before the child left we
performed rapid whole genome sequencing
in accordance with our protocol and this
is one of those cases where the
physician had a pretty strong suspicion
of what it could be they actually talked
to us beforehand to see Abe you cooker
the EB CC gene well and so we were able
to actually go through the process of
checking that gene upfront making sure
that it was covered well but putting it
through our normal process we tried to
perform the sequencing interpretation
reporting as fast as we could and this
was a case where the physician
suspicions lined up with the genetic
and that as you can see here we put in
the phenotypic driven prioritization
along with the variant filtering from
the whole genome data and we came to a
classification of a pathogenic variant
in a bcc8
that was paternally inherited which is
actually very important for the genetics
downstream and so the ABC CA variant we
found a stop in variant and there was a
lot of literature on this period there
was over 35 papers that were out there
so even though we thought confident the
diagnosis really had to come through the
literature and really try and read what
was known about this genetic diagnosis
and what it could mean downstream in
terms of the impact for the child and
what is known in the literature in terms
of treatment and prognostic value so as
you can see here with the software tool
and we're able to capture a lot of those
papers up front which is great for a
person in my shoes that's really trying
to capture as much information as
possible and so we're able to make a
genetic diagnosis thigh for insulin emia
for this particular child and this is an
interesting case and this really speaks
to the power of having the parents
available for the testing so the
diagnosis it actually is very important
to know which parent the mutation comes
from and so in this particular case
coming from the father there then was a
suspicion about being focal
hyperinsulinemia which is actually a
much better outcome potential outcome
for this child compared to having a
diffuse hyperinsulinemia so with the
molecular diagnosis in hand prognosis
does look better for this child if it
clinically confirms to be focal
hyperinsulinemia they're able to remove
the sections of the pancreas that have
that are altered and as opposed to
removing the whole pancreas and when
that occurs the child will be diabetic
and will be a type 1 diabetic for their
whole life which again the child can
live but it can be very hard to manage
and has down statements locations
and so this is you know a little bit to
speak to the kaijin platform and how
it's helped us and being able to provide
rapid diagnosis for the children so we
have to ensure all parts of our process
are well regulated as well as making
sure that they're done as quickly as
possible having content within one shot
within one-click way is very important
for our team and being able to
prioritize experience using a network
analytics is very important to use so
again we're trying to provide rapid
diagnosis where ours could be vital for
the further downstream implications for
this child so we're again really trying
to push the envelope providing a short
of a turnaround time as possible we at
the same time need to make sure that
we're doing our diligence reading all
the papers using all the databases that
are out there make sure that we provide
accurate classifications for the
importance of these diagnoses in that if
we make misdiagnosis for this child it
can have a lot of downstream impacts as
well using the ACMG guidelines or
standard standard variant classification
that came up 2015 we really try to
adhere to that framework and again being
able to toggle back and forth between
different views different filtering
mechanism is important for us because
you know these genetic guide
diseases are all rare we're coming
across new phenotypes all the time in
these kids new diagnoses that nothing is
known about it so we really have to do
our best to provide the diligence that
we can so what is our big picture here
so right now our focus has been the
children at the NICU at Rady Children's
Hospital but as we look at the problem
more globally you can see that there are
thousands and thousands of kids that
need this testing that aren't able to
access it and you can see that in terms
of the number of diagnoses that can be
performed in San Diego in California and
the United States the numbers are really
hard to comprehend and you know I know I
keep
us up at night thinking that there are a
lot of children out there that would
really benefit from this testing that
aren't able to get it right now and you
know there are roadblocks to that
adoption that we're trying to tackle
we're trying to go after for that
ultimate goal of having this be a test
that all children that need it are able
to get it to be able to give them a
better life downstream so the big
question who pays for it so currently
medical insurance does not reimburse
this type of testing so clinical whole
genome sequencing although there are
other labs that provide clinical whole
genome sequencing the vast majority of
reimbursed tests in the genomic testing
world are exomes
and that's because excellence at this
point are cheaper tests there's a lot
more data out there in terms of exomes
and rare and rare non diagnosed genetic
disease and so we we think genomic
sequencing is ultimately the platform
that needs to be used because it will
always be the fastest technology using
PCR free it'll always allow us to
interpret and comprehend the most the
vast majority of the genome that we know
about and so we're really hoping to
provide the body of evidence for rapid
whole genome sequencing so the field
lacks the large clinical trial study to
show the patient economic benefits so
what do the insurance companies want to
see they want to see that this testing
is helpful for patients it has economic
benefit it has downstream clinical
utility for these patients so we're
trying to design the proper studies
within our system and other potential
partners to really try and show the body
of evidence that this testing compared
to the standard of care right now the
superior and all these key metrics that
insurance companies are looking for and
so we plan to provide that evidence to
change medicine forever and so again we
really view clinical rapid whole genome
sequencing as a first year test for
these kids in the intensive care unit
and we see
it in small studies that have been
published and some that have not been
published yet providing a huge benefit
in terms of diagnosis and clinical
utility but we need to show bigger
numbers so we want to ask the questions
of the field are asking once the output
look like genomes compared to exomes
other things look if you sequence the
entire family versus just sequencing the
probe and of interest and how do you
automate some of these processes how do
you make it a scalable test so we just
done you know a few cases within our
experience here at r84 we're looking to
scale that up and work with other
partners to help us scale up this
approach because again we need to
provide testing to a lot more children
and center getting it right now and so
with that we have a rapidly growing team
at their Rady Children's is - for
genomic medicine I'm one in a team again
this photo is even outdated we've added
a lot of other members to our team since
since this was done and so we are really
you know looking forward to working with
others and kind of sharing our message
and how we're approaching this problem
that that we do is a serious public
health problem and I think everybody for
the further time here and I'll leave you
with this note that the children are
waiting and so hopefully we can provide
this testing to more and more kids out
there thank you very much
you
you
Thank You dr. Chow to hurry for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on that green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on the screen and click that send button
will answer as many questions as you
have time for so let's get started with
the questions our first audience member
would like to know what is the average
turnaround time of results sequencing
takes an average of five days the
interpretation varies depending on oh go
ahead sir okay thanks for the question
that is that's a really important
question and that's a common question
many of the people who are getting into
India sequence they generally take an
average of about five days to finish
depending on the sample type and but and
the interpretation varies depending on
that negative and positive results and
the clinical confirmations as needed and
what kind of software is used for
interpretation so the kind of software
that we can get directly to see I
interpret or PCI that we get these
software's are designed for easy
interpretation and faster growth I'll
pass the time is in better response so
but still it a lot depends on whether
the results are negative or positive and
therefore thank you
looks like we have time for one more
question do you report secondary and
incidental findings right now our study
does not report a second to your
incidental findings we just are focused
on symptom driven diagnosis for the
children
great thank you so much hi there I this
issue mulch Audrey that just turned on
the line I apologize for being late so
if there's any other questions from the
audience I'm happy to take them great we
do have one more question from the
audience member how would rapid whole
genome sequencing compared with exome
sequencing in terms of the time required
and the clinically relevant information
to be gained so this is a great question
that that the field is asking in a
question that we have as well in terms
of the current landscape clinical exome
sequence clinical exome sequencing is
being offered by variety of laboratories
that are delivering high quality
products from the laboratory technical
aspect we do think that whole genome
sequencing can be performed a little bit
faster in the laboratory side of things
and that doesn't require a capture
procedure and we do see the potential
for whole genome sequencing having some
advantages in terms of being able to
detect different types of variation
within a single platform structural
variants as well as snv's and small
insertions and deletions so you know I
think one of the big considerations for
laboratories is that it's cheaper to run
exome sequencing right now and most of
the variation that we did detect right
now is focused on on the on the exome
and so I think that's why it's being
offered clinically and being reimbursed
more than genomes right now we do see
the potential for four genomes to be
faster and potentially have the highest
clinical sensitivity compared to other
approaches out there for for rare and
undiagnosed disease wonderful thank you
so much do you have any closing remarks
you'd like to add dr. shattering yeah so
thank you again for the platform and I
apologize for coming in a little bit
late you know here at the Institute we
really trying to ask some of the
questions of what it would take to to
implement this test
to become the new standard of care and
so we're actually gonna be running some
clinical trials to look at exome versus
genome singleton versus trio analysis
and try to look at that systematically
to look at outcomes and look at the
economics so we're eager to you know to
work with other children's hospitals or
other people that are out there
interested in sequencing in infants and
in the tensive care units so so please
you know reach out to us and I think
it's a very exciting time with the new
technologies for for this type of
testing and the positive impact it can
have for patients worldwide thank you so
much to dr. Taher and thank you for your
colleagues for stepping in for a couple
of minutes for to answer those two
questions I'd also like to thank kyochon
and lab roots for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through August 2017
you will receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when the webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now enjoy the conference
thanks for joining us we hope to see you
again soon bye bye